in der krise trennt sich die spreu vom
weizen wer weizen und wer streut ist
wird an wahlabenden abschließend
entschieden also sollten die politisch
verantwortlichen der pandemie bekämpfung
auf der hut sein ein glückliches
händchen haben bisher nicht alle
bewiesen zu wenig impfstoff zu viel
lockdown krisen management in der krise
jetzt in der phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde herzlich willkommen bei
uns meine gäste zunächst jedem studio
die freie wissenschaftsjournalistin
christina story und stephan andreas
casdorff langjähriger chefredakteur und
jetzt herausgeber des berliner
tagesspiegel
zugeschaltet ist uns durch neubauer für
die spd bürgermeister in augustusburg
das ist eine 4400 einwohner stadt im
landkreis mittelsachsen wer in der
schule im geografieunterricht an diesem
tag abgängig war noch die information 16
kilometer östlich von chemnitz sie haben
gerade entsteht sozusagen in ihrer feder
ein buch mit dem titel rettet die
demokratie eine überfällige
streitschrift die hat auch einiges mit
der sendung heute zu tun und ebenfalls
zugeschaltet ist uns mark schieritz
wirtschaftspolitischer korrespondent der
wochenzeitung die zeit erneut bauer wie
ist die stimmung wenn man sagt fragt das
klingt ein bisschen nach kirmes aber
kriegen sie sind unter einer minute hin
gerät nachher noch ausführlicher darüber
was das bedeutet mit diesen pandemie
problem jeden tag in augustusburg
konfrontiert zu sein also mit dem was
sie da erleben
ja ich will es mal versuchen eine minute
die stimmung ist angespannt
es geht für viele leute um die existenz
das ist die eine seite die wir immer
ganz gern einen euro berechnen
aber wir beobachten auch dass das
miteinander so langsam aber sicher
schaden nimmt und ich glaube dass wir
momentan noch gar nicht richtig
überblicken können welche schäden dieses
dieser lockdown generiert hat in diesen
monaten erschwere jetzt könnte man denn
die grundstimmung hier im land als
überwiegend deprimiert bezeichnen
ja es ist auf jeden fall erkennbar sich
verschlechtern
in allen bereichen glaube ich das bild
ist weil das private sich auch nicht für
für das politische und das hat einfach
damit zu tun dass natürlich nach all
diesen
monaten neu ausgezählt sind und die
lösungen und die besseren zeiten die
eigentlich schon für den frühjahr
versprochen sind auch erwartet waren
das wird sich aber noch ziehen wir haben
es wieder steigenden zahlen im swr
sommer hinein dauern und ist kein wunder
die leute sind einfach wirklich ein
bisschen am ende
castorf tatsächlich klingen ja manche
schilderungen als sei man hierzulande an
bord der titanic und zwar nach der
begegnung mit dem eisberg wird die
politik bei uns unter wert dargestellt
oder stellt sich die politik selbst
unter wert da ganz schwierige frage also
es ist eine ungewöhnlich schwierige
situation in der noch keine regierung
war das manchmal konzedieren war auch
ihnen zugestehen
das ist wie heißt das immer so schön
wenn wir schon im titanic wir bleiben
das panik orchester spielt und wir
fahren auf sicht praktisch muss jeden
tag neu entschieden werden auf grundlage
von zahlen auf grundlage von von
unterschiedlichen einflüssen
die politik tut aber auch nicht genug um
zu erklären warum sieht die dinge so
macht wie sie es macht also politik ist
seit den alten griechen police are go
reich stelle mich hin und versuchen den
menschen zu erklären warum das was ich
tue möglicherweise richtig sei und sie
mir vielleicht darin folgen möchten
und gerade in diesen zeiten in denen sie
so viel ändern muss das umso mehr
geschehen um so häufiger geschehen du
musst um verständnis vertrauen werben
und glaubwürdig bleiben und das ist
natürlich ein enormes problem eine
enorme herausforderung und die politik
wird dem nicht immer gerecht da kommt
dann das was er sagt die leute malu
dreyer sagt das über die leute sind
ausgezählt das zerrt an unseren nerven
und volker bouffier der nun im moment
der moderator der ganzen situation im
kabinett bzw mit den ministerpräsidenten
war und ist der gesagt die leute an die
schnauze voll so drastisch und so ist es
dann auch und die politik verkauft sich
selbst tatsächlich auch unter wert man
muss ja konzentrieren dass die kanzlerin
sich dabei praktisch als biologin
betätigt ob das immer so richtig sind
immer so gut ist das kommt jetzt auf den
prüfstand weil die leute sagen ja die
wissen sie auch nicht besser
das ist das wovon wahrscheinlicher neuer
schreibt pastor i egal was sonst
passiert das a und o ist ja das impfen
jetzt auch wieder mit pastor senica ist
da trotz allem
optimismus gerechtfertigt gibt es
vielleicht doch dieses grüne licht am
ende des tunnels in absehbarer zeit
nahmen ganz sicher kann man es nicht
sagen das haben wir jetzt gesehen das
hat man immer wieder gesehen in dieser
partie ist kann immer etwas dazwischen
kommen wenn das alles jetzt so läuft
dann wird im sommer ist schon deutlich
heller seien ganz klar aber das sind
halt doch ein paar wochen bis dahin und
das sind ganz schlimme wochen die jetzt
kommen werden weil das sieht ja jeder
die inzidenz sowie viele virologen ist
vorhergesagt haben
die übrigens auch des öfteren recht
gehabt haben es gibt viele logen
epidemiologen die waren sind seit
monaten immer richtig in ihr vorhersagen
und das sind die die auch gesagt haben
werden wir öffnen vor zwei wochen dann
wird es schlechter werden und das wird
es und es wird in den nächsten wochen
dann wahrscheinlich auf
intensivstationen schlechter werden das
impfen wird greifen aber das dauert noch
bevor wir hier weiter hinten schauen wir
uns noch den o-ton des tages an
es spricht der bundesgesundheitsminister
unser ziel ist es und das ist das
gemeinsame ziel von bund und allen 16
bundesländern da schon morgen im laufe
des tages wieder mit impfungen mit astra
zenica in deutschland begonnen werden
kann
darüber sind wir uns einig beim bund und
ländern dass wir mit getragen und
unterstützt vom paul-ehrlich-institut
und auch die ständige impfkommission hat
sich mehrheitlich für ein solches
vorgehen ausgesprochen
das ist ein wichtiges gemeinsames
zeichen wenn man jetzt sich die woche
ansieht am montag wurde
astrazeneca aus dem verkehr gezogen
am freitag kommt es jetzt wieder zum
einsatz war dass die ganze aufregung
wert denn das politische
fieberthermometer ist in den letzten
tagen wegen dieses vorgangs doch noch
mal heftig angestiegen aber was hätte
der armee sparen muss man in diesem
falle sagen machen dass man nicht wie
ich meine
das geht nun wirklich nicht da kommt das
paul-ehrlich-institut sagen wir sollten
da mal prüfen
da kann kein verantwortlicher und schon
gar kein politiker hingehen und sagen
was man auf ist egal wir impfen weiter
ich bin auch sehr dafür impfen impfen
impfen ich verstehe nicht dass wir das
nicht so machen können wie in amerika wo
da ganz anders angegangen wird wo es ein
politisches ziel gibt wo es eine klare
richtung gibt wo jetzt sanitäter und
medizinisches personal und apotheker und
die
jetzt soll alle jetzt impfen ich
verstehe nicht dass wir das irgendwie
nicht hinkriegen das muss einfacher
gehen
ich behaupte auch es geht einfach den
politischen willen vorausgesetzt aber in
diesem falle muss ich sagen war es
richtig und es wäre gegen jeden rat
gewesen und auch gegen politische
klugheit die leute hätten gesagt sie
seien verrückt ich meinte neubauer auch
ja eigentlich mit der aufregung dass die
reaktion der anderen es wurde ja auch
entspannen da sozusagen als buhmann
hingestellt dass er diese entscheidung
getroffen hat sind wir in einer solchen
situation zu aufgeregt und war es das
wert diese woche darüber sich so ich
sage jetzt mal salopp das maul zu
zerreißen und jetzt wo ja absehbar war
dass die europäische arzneimittelagentur
das wieder zulassen wird
na ja wir sind schon ein bisschen
momentan sogar panikorchester na also es
wird ja wirklich jeder halbsatz und und
jedes verrückte komma einmal quer durch
die republik debattiert ich möchte mich
aber anschließend ist glaubt tatsächlich
dass wir wahnsinnig komplex sind und
dass das für den bürger ob tatsächlich
nicht mehr nachvollziehbar ist und das
ist ein großes problem
aber dann wenn politik nicht mehr
nachvollziehbar ist und sich nicht mehr
erklären kann vor allen dingen wird es
schwierig und gerade wenn du das impfen
beispielsweise nehmen also ich hab das
ja hier bei uns im ort verfolgt als
unsere senioreneinrichtung geimpft
worden sind wenn sie diesen personellen
aufwand und diese diese bürokratie
schlacht einmal beobachtet haben dass
apotheker eine spritze aufziehen muss
eine schwester impft ein arzt aufklärt
und drei weitere personen den
achtseitigen papier krieg pro zu impfen
oder personen abarbeiten muss dann
brauchen wir uns auch nicht zu wundern
dass wir nicht vorwärtskommen und das
verstehen menschen dann auch nicht mehr
und der nächste punkt ist dass man
ausgerechnet also gerade im freistaat
sachsen wo was mit der digitalisierung
ja erkennbar nicht so gut haben dass man
ausgerechnet bei der zielgruppe 80plus
darauf kommt eine impf anmeldung online
zu machen
das ist schon einigermaßen unterhaltsam
ein kabarettist können sie sich das
nicht was ausdenken
es wäre jetzt was läuft in der politik
gerade ab mit mal auf diese aufregung
wegen astrazeneca stephan andreas
casdorff hat gesagt das war gar nicht
anders zu machen hat ja auch wirklich
absehbar jetzt dazu geführt dass der
impfstoff wieder zugelassen wird was
machen wir eigentlich wenn es noch ganz
andere probleme gibt
mit der pandemie bekämpfung also ich
glaube auch dass wir ein bisschen
hysterisch oder drohen des ministeriums
zu werden
es liegt aber glaube ich durchaus was
ich auch schon angesprochen oder eine
kommunikation als ich das gesehen habe
dienstagnachmittag habe ich was zunächst
mal ohne hintergrund hat fragt man sich
natürlich schon wie kann es sein dass
irgendwer auftreten
der schaden der angerichtet wird durch
das nicht viel größer verlegen für die
wirtschaft und so weiter als hätte diese
riesigen kauf zu nehmen so ich kann aber
total nachvollziehen dass der
gesundheitsminister wenn die
wissenschaftliche empfehlung ist
vorsicht muss man genauer hinschauen das
macht dann auch macht nur es war glaube
ich auch nicht ideal erklärt am anfang
ich wollte zu dem impfen generell noch
was sagen ich bin total auch dabei zu
sagen das muss drin bürokratisiert und
vereinfacht werden muss aber auch wissen
dass wir in deutschland halt auch unsere
regeln sehr lieben also was werden los
gewesen wenn wir von anfang an gesagt
hätten
im format wer durch wer zuerst kommt der
krieg den stock dann letztendlich
geschichten darüber gegeben dass sie
erreichen schneller dran sind oder in
einem land in bankkreisen das in anderen
landkreisen und so weiter das kann man
alles machen aber ich glaube da muss man
sich auch dann muss man bereits
startbereit sein sich diesen debatten zu
stellen und man darf ja auch nicht
vergessen dass ich am anfang auch nicht
genug impfstoff hatten das wird jetzt
hochgefahren und die prognosen und
berechnungen die ich kenne
sie sind gar nicht so schlecht also wir
können bis juli durch sein mit der
impfung
wenn wir das einigermaßen steigern auf
von 600.000 euro brauche irgendwann das
ist nicht total unrealistisch
also wir werden glaube ich am ende gar
nicht so weit hinterher sein hinter
ländern wie großbritannien
foto ri wenn wir uns mal ein best case
szenario angucken in der besten aller
welten das in form streitet jetzt voran
es kommen genügend impfstoff sogar die
digitalisierung kommt in gang
es wird es herrscht große freude über
das öffnen von läden von restaurants und
dann kommt eine neue bislang unbekannte
aggressive mutante was passiert dann
ich glaube da muss man als unpraktisch
ist es reichlich unwahrscheinlich also
die studien sagen eigentlich was man so
bisher überblicken kann
wenn es dann noch eine mutante gebe eine
andere fiese dann werde ich schon
aufgetaucht also man sieht dass das was
auftaucht in den verschiedenen ländern
sind immer die gleichen mutationen das
spricht sehr dafür dass das die ideal
fiesel mutationen sind aber sagen wir
mal was passiert da weiß die da wissen
die impfstoffhersteller jetzt schon sie
könnten das innerhalb von zwei monaten
anpassen und die agentur die also die
zulassungsbehörden die haben jetzt schon
vorbereitet für den fall dass das
notwendig ist dass man dann auch nicht
mehr bei null anfängt man muss dann
nicht mehr 30.000 leute testen sondern
dann könnte man beschleunigt das
verfahren haben
also man könnte die m rna impfstoffe
denn macht man eine andere m rna rhein
bei den vektor impfstoffen könnte man
auch was basteln
das wäre alles möglich das wäre alles
handhabbar und es wäre nicht mehr so
eine unangenehme situation wie sie jetzt
haben wo die leute die kurve 19 noch
nicht hatten die noch nicht infiziert
waren und noch nicht geimpft waren noch
gar keine gar keine leichte immunität
haben bei der grippe haben wir das ja
auch dass man nach der zeit so ein
bisschen dagegen gewappnet ist das haben
wir bei cupid 90 und das werden wir aber
in ein zwei jahren haben das heißt dann
sind wir auch besser gewappnet gegen
irgend welche mutationen es geht ja um
die krisen reaktionsfähigkeit von
politik wenn sie also schon mit solchen
schwierigkeiten zu bekommen muss wie
jetzt in der abgelaufenen woche was
passiert eigentlich dann wenn wirklich
etwas unvorhergesehenes schwer zu
händeln das passiert ausgerechnet in
einem wahljahr will ich widersprechen
dass es ist ja unvorhersehbaren schwer
zu händeln also die ganze zeit das ist
ja dann kommt die mutante und dann ich
will nur eines sagen ich verstehe das
alles dann verstehe ich auch wieder
nicht also es hat ja ein bisschen was
mit aussagen logik zu tun tatsächlich
mit tig aus erfolgt b also wir können
wenn wahr ist dass es jetzt schon 3,3
billionen gekostet hat was wir machen
unter anderem mit den kindern 3,3
millionen sage nicht ich sondern
bildungsforscher oecd bildungsexperte
die nicht zu bekritteln sind würde ich
mal sagen das sind keine corona leugner
oder alu hütte die sagen wir hätten
jetzt schon 3,3 millionen kosten für die
volkswirtschaft in den kommenden jahren
das ist so viel wie das wie die
wirtschaftsleistung in deutschland im
jahr 2020
wir können nicht von lockdown zu lockern
zu locken zu locker angehen wir müssen
das ganz anders anfassen
die politik muss und das ist die
herausforderung die muss das thema jetzt
anders anpassen ich weiß nicht wie man
mit dem virus leben kann wir müssen auch
mit der grippe leben das kann man nicht
vergleichen
wie gesagt ich will mich da nicht
ärztlich jetzt einmischen ich sage nur
so wie es jetzt geht geht es vor dem
hintergrund was wir alle gemeinsam
besprochen haben die leute sind am ende
die leute haben keine lust mehr sie
können nicht mehr so geht es nicht
weiter wenn jetzt eine mutante kommt und
wir lockt dann bis ende des jahres haben
dann ist es so dass die leute fertig
sind aber auch unser ganzes anderes
leben fertig ist noch sehen wir es nicht
in den innenstädten aber wir werden es
sehen und es gibt ideen also es gibt den
boris palmer in tübingen der andere
sachen macht es gibt den traunstein plan
es gibt erneut
es gibt menschen die sich andere pläne
machen und sagen wir müssen das anders
anpacken schnelltests zweimal die woche
dann kannst du dich bewegen wenn du den
vorweisen ganz so ein match wie so ein
bvg hier also in ein verkehrs ticket
damit du dann in die läden gehen kannst
wir müssen anders rangehen sonst werden
auch wir die menschen verlieren und wir
werden sie radikalisieren weil ich sagen
ich will das nicht mehr
wir haben selber keine ahnung damit sind
wir beim eröffnungs konzept des
bürgermeisters von augustusburg herr
neubauer
sie haben sich etwas überlegt den lock
down zu verhindern obwohl hier auch in
ihrer stadt die inzidenz die die
inzidenz zahlen ja auch relativ hoch
sind in augustusburg was wollen sie was
plan sehen naja ich war das nicht
alleine also das ist eine zusammenarbeit
von vielen bausteinen also wir als stadt
die oberwiesenthaler
tourismusunternehmer privatunternehmen
ist mit dabei also wir haben uns kurz
und gut was ausgedacht was relativ
simpel dass wir haben ein elektronisches
ticket das wird per email versandt mit
diesem ticket gehen sie zu ihrem
schnelltest zentrum das haben wir jetzt
schon im betrieb seit einer woche loggen
sich sat 1 wollen sich den test ab der
qr-code wird bei negativen tests zur
eintrittskarte
damit können sie über einchecken in der
gastro im museum im einzelhandel aller
drei tage müssen sie quasi diesen tür
akkus wie eine telefonkarte mit dem
neuen test aufladen
machen sie das nicht haben sie keinen
zutritt mehr wir merken jetzt schon wir
haben über 700 anmeldungen für diese
tests inzwischen wir haben zwar noch
tests in den letzten drei tagen gemacht
das heißt also wenn die menschen sehen
dass sie etwas davon haben werden ist
die test bereitschaft da und wir testen
jetzt natürlich erst mal die
dunkelziffer raus aber wenn sie nach
tübingen in rostock schauen das sind ja
so die erfolgreichsten städte dann ist
genau das zunächst passiert testen
testen testen
das zum beispiel was weiß ich leider
nicht verstanden habe dass wir das nicht
grundsätzlich schon gemacht haben diese
tests sind verfügbar gewesen schon sehr
lange wir hätten als kommune das viel
früher machen wollen wir durften sie
nicht kaufen also eigentlich völlig
absurd auch das wird die schulen öffnen
ohne dort wirklich ein richtiges test
geschrieben zu haben kann ja alles nicht
nachvollziehen das könnte man alles tun
wir machen das jetzt wir haben uns
durchgesetzt ich freue mich auch dass
unser unsere landesregierung trotz
großer bedenken und jetzt grünes licht
gibt wir verhandeln jetzt noch über den
konkreten starttermin und noch ein
letzter satz zu incidents bei 4500
einwohnern
reichen ihnen zehn positive fälle um
eine sensationelle incidents von 220
kommt etwas zu produzieren
also ich bitte da auch ein bisschen
darum dass man gerade bei den kleineren
städten vielleicht auch noch ein paar
andere benchmarks nutzt beispielsweise
krankenhaus beleben oder wir reden
tatsächlich mal wieder überall wird der
kurioserweise aus der diskussion völlig
verschwunden ist wurde wir schauen dass
man wie viele leute von dem erzählt
neubauer liegt damit bei 122 also
insofern der 1 100 stecken 122 anteile
an wenn das collage gegeben jetzt habe
ich gelernt aber dieser wert ist ja wird
ja jetzt jedoch auch ins spiel gebrachte
neubauer wenn das eröffnungs konzept das
wir jetzt das geziert haben kein erfolg
hat wenn sie denn ziehen andere
parameter wie vielleicht auch
bettenbelegung intensivstation wieder
hoch gehen haben sie dann auch ein
lockdown konzept naja also was heißt
lockt ein konzept wir müssen jetzt sehen
und wir sind uns auch relativ sicher wir
haben auch virologen mit dem projekt das
ganze wird auch wissenschaftlich
begleitet wir haben auch stochastischer
dabei die rechnen können
also wir gehen schon davon aus wenn wir
diese diese theoretischen zahlen die wir
jetzt haben auf diesen vier monats
doktor und dezenter uns haben legen
würden hätte es bedeutet dass wir im
monat länger hätten öffnen können und
wahrscheinlich schon im monat früher
wieder öffnen können und das ist
volkswirtschaftlich gesehen schon ein
riesenerfolg aber was noch viel
wichtiger ist und darüber reden wir viel
zu wenig was das mit den menschen macht
sie können sich nicht vorstellen was
hier in der region los ist seitdem die
aussicht darauf da ist dass wir dies
machen können mit welcher disziplin die
leute agierenden nach welcher freude
welche freude da jetzt da ist das ist
endlich mal sowas gibt wie zumindest wir
versuchen mal was wir wissen ja noch
nicht was dabei rauskommt aber wenn wir
es nicht versuchen wenn wir solche
zahlen nicht erheben in solchen
projekten dann werden wir natürlich auch
nicht schlauer sein
und wenn wir pech haben und wir haben im
herbst 21 replay von 20 dann weiß ich
dass bei uns unserer stadt ganz viele
unternehmen das nicht überstehen werden
ganz sicher nicht wenn man das gerät
sich anhört ist das auch ein plädoyer
dafür kompetenzen zuständigkeiten mehr
von oben nach unten und durchzugeben
auch initiativen nicht abzublocken von
zu unterstützen es gibt ja auch ein
unglaubliches kompetenzgerangel zwischen
den verschiedenen ebenen läuft da auch
in unserem ganzen system was falsch also
ich glaube schon dass es richtig ist
experimente auf lokaler ebene zu lassen
und
was davon zu lernen auch für die nächste
krise ich würde auch sagen dass das
klingt jetzt muss was soll nicht noch
nicht verschwörungstheoretiker klingen
aber dass man nicht mechanistisch auf
den inzidenz wert schaut das würde ich
schon auch sagen wenn ich glaube das
ergibt sich auch zwangsläufig denn je
mehr menschen gm seinen werden desto
weniger menschen werden bei einer
gegebenen anzahl von einer infizierten
sterben so dass es sich dass man zwar
alles ausmachen dabei den stärken hat
jetzt die jungen oder die 50 jährigen
aber trotzdem natürlich sehr größe ist
nicht aussuchen wird sich im zeitablauf
ändern
ich bin mir nur nicht sicher ob
sozusagen das in dieser jetzigen phase
der krise in der wir sind wo wir
wirklich noch wahrscheinlich 5678 total
harte wochen haben werden bevor die
impfungen dann richtig greifen
ob da diese modelle uns sehr viel
weiterhelfen also in österreich testet
ihr auch sehr viele schulen usw aber hat
extrem steigen erklärt ja auch jetzt
wieder also und dann ob man da jetzt
auch eine landesweite oder bundesweiten
ebene ist eine art von abkürzung findet
da da bin ich mir nicht sicher
auch gut einen kurztrip zu lernen
ja aber es ist ja auch es ist ja nicht
so dass das ist politik sich hinstellt
und sagt jetzt wollen nicht testen also
das ist ja keine neue idee das ist ja
toll dass sie das umsetzen
an vielen ecken und enden fehlen die ja
noch ich meine jeder versucht ja diese
selbst festungen zu bekommen viele
schulen hätten die gerne weil es
natürlich sinnvoller gewesen wäre die
schulen erst dann zu öffnen wenn man da
ein anständiges test konzept hat da gebe
ich ihnen völlig recht wo ich ihn nicht
recht gäbe ist dass es schon vor wochen
diese tests gab nicht in den mengen dass
man ganz deutschland hätte versorgen
können und nicht an geprüft also das
finde ich auch gut dass in deutschland
gesagt wurde
wir gucken erst sind die laien sicher
man muss man hören wie die leute sich
anstellen wenn sie jetzt diesen selbst
fest selber machen wie man da vor sich
hin busselt ob das richtig klappt das
schon gut dass seine anständige
anleitung drin ist und dass das geprüft
wurde bevor es auf den markt kommt
das dauert natürlich das wurde zu früh
versprochen aber ich möchte auch mal
daran erinnern
wir sind nicht das einzige land in
dieser pandemie ich glaube den franzosen
und spaniern und italienern und auch den
amerikanern hits nicht besser als ich
glaube die haben es alle bisher oder
keiner mag diese lockdown also erheblich
schneller
man darf auch nicht so einfach ist ja
gucken weil die es viel einfacher haben
nicht die haben die menschen alle
registriert die geniale zum militär da
weiß man die persönlichen daten das ist
nicht so kompliziert über uns da ist das
thema datenschutz ein ganz anderes das
darf man auch nicht vergessen
und dennoch ich komme darauf zurück dass
thun zeigt das wollen und ich glaube
dass es ganz notwendig ist dass es jetzt
voran geht und dass die leute
tatsächlich auch wie er sagt das ist ein
lohn für das was ich mir an zu tun habe
und was ich gerne tue um solidarisch zu
sein und in dieser gesellschaft
mitzuwirken möchte ich aber auch wissen
dass es nicht ein tunnel am ende des
lichts gibt ich möchte nicht in dürren
matschen tunnel ich möchte leben dürfen
und das muss eine verheißung sein und
für die verheißung musst du einen lohn
erfahren alles das was die leute tun wir
haben doch ich meine in diesem land in
dem herr stöhr der vero experte sagt
können wir die 50er inzidenz gar nicht
schaffen da sind 120 oder 160 schon
schön und damit kann man auch leben
das will ich nicht werden in der einen
noch in der anderen seite nur wir hatten
schon 50er incidents und was haben die
leute davon gehört ja prima jetzt sollte
ich 35 kommen das war ein
kommunikationsfehler der unvergleichlich
war weil die leute gesagt okay jetzt
haben wir uns so viel mühe gegeben wir
waren so disziplinen jetzt ist muss die
35er seien aber kein mensch kann
erklären oder erklärt warum 35 jetzt
sein muss und wissen aber ich habe
meinen verstand wegen der mutation das
wurde wirklich häufig erklärt ist jeder
hat man kriegt das kurz vor weihnachten
als man dachte jetzt kommt also wir
haben das wirklich tagtäglich im radio
gesagt also wenn sie das nicht
mitbekommen haben dass die mutation
gefährlicher also haben sie unterbricht
kann ich kann lothar späth steht das oft
ja so was ich sagen wollte einmal kurzen
was ich sagen wollte ist es wurde sehr
häufig erklärt die 35 ist die neue 50
weil sich die situation geändert hat wir
haben ein anderes virus das ist
gefährlicher und wird in unserem
eintreten dass die 35 eine
wissenschaftliche größe soll diese auch
nur griff
wir wissen alle dass auch auf die
intensivbetten geguckt wird die übrigens
schlechter ist die situation als im
letzten herbst weil die betten sind noch
nicht wieder frei na also es ist besser
geworden aber es ist nicht so dass
wieder viele freie waffen sehen
vielleicht herrn schieritz zu wort
kommen weil ich glaube es nicht im
umfeld von anspruch
wurde der internationalen vergleichen
ich habe so ein bisschen den eindruck
dass wir uns gerade in der debatte hier
in jedem land das heraussuchen was gut
oder super läuft man sagen dass mir das
nicht also uk zum beispiel
großbritannien zwischen toll aber
ansonsten ist er gar nichts die
arbeitslosigkeit ist ja die schulung ist
wieder der wachstumseinbruch war größer
es gibt immer noch ein loch daumen
paris hat heute nacht oder jetzt gerade
eben in neuenmarkt angeschlossen italien
noch dann geschlossen es ist jetzt nicht
so dass man wenn man sich umschaut in
der westlichen welt sei jetzt bewusst
westlichen werden dass man asien außen
vor dass man dann sagen würde war wir
sind so schlecht und ja andere machen
das alles super im gegenteil ich glaube
dass deutschland so ich habe es nicht
mal angeschaut ist systematisch das sind
mir so im oberen weil das ja nicht so
schlecht
wir können reden was die tüte in der tat
besser machen oder länder wie australien
da gibt es da gibt es einen unterschied
aber wenn wir uns jetzt mal in europa
umschauen dann ist da kein land ist
richtig gut oder überzeugen durch diese
krise kommen ein passant trösten dass er
gleich noch dann mit was mit der krise
zu tun und nicht nicht nur mit klingt
natürlich auch ein bisschen milder der
umstände für die politiker neubauer ein
bürgermeister der kann ja nicht
unerkannt über die straße laufen sie
haben tuchfühlung zur bevölkerung haben
sie manchmal das gefühl dass vielleicht
auch die bevölkerung von der politik
angefangen bei der kommunalpolitik etwas
zu viel erwartet dazu anspruchsvoll ist
vielleicht auch zu ungeduldig ja aber
wundern wir uns jetzt das haben wir uns
ja alles selber gebaut
also ich kann da nur für mein rät ihr
reden also vielleicht für den osten da
kenne ich mich glaube ich ganz gut aus
wenn ich die 30 jahre zurück spule seit
dem mauerfall dann haben die leute hier
im ort jedoch von der politik gehört
bleiben sie ruhig für ruinöse hier wurde
über jahrzehnte allen vieles versprochen
und jetzt wenn es eng wird erwarten wir
bloß sinn wo soll er denn herkommen also
das ist ja ein bisschen was er hat ein
bisschen was von kindererziehung die
irgendwie schief gegangen ist
und man muss den leuten ja schon
irgendwie sagen ihr seid in erster linie
selber verantwortlich
und diese erwartungshaltung die wir
jetzt bedienen müssen also dieser
lieferservice politik der kann ja gar
nicht funktionieren
und das muss man irgendwann auch mal
wieder im klaren haupt setzen umdrehen
den leuten sagen wir machen das hier
ganz gern mal also wenn hier jemand
kommt und sagt die stadt muss man
irgendwie dann sagt ich in der regel du
bist die stadt ich bin die
stadtverwaltung um das auch mal klar zu
machen also wir müssen uns wieder dazu
kommen den leuten mehr zu vertrauen und
mehr zuzutrauen und vielleicht ist das
auch etwas was uns die pandemie gerade
so zeigt dieser permanente zeigefinger
der sich so durch diese gar dass das
ganze politische administration jetzt
zieht
und ja mittlerweile tatsächlich die
kommune als kleinste demokratische
vollständig vernachlässigt und
entmündigt nahezu das muss aufhören und
wir müssen uns nicht wundern dass
menschen nicht mehr davon überzeugt sind
dass sich selber wirken können wenn wir
ihn gar keine möglichkeiten mehr
einräumen zu wirken dass das ist ein
kausaler zusammenhang und da müssen wir
auch immer die pandemie macht das nur
sichtbar das ist kein problem der
pandemie das ist etwas das schon sehr
lange sehr schleichend funktioniert hat
vertrauen sagt man ja seit das größte
kapital das größte politische kapital
wird das gerade aufgezehrt
logischerweise weil das jetzt so eine
situation ist in der tatsächlich vieles
von vertrauen habe ich erneut wird man
hält es gibt ja im grunde genommen nur
zwei möglichkeiten
das eine ist noko witt wir schließen das
land ab weil sie drei wochen vier wochen
und gucken was passiert und hoffen
abgesehen davon dass im berchtesgadener
land eine inzidenz und 252 war dann gab
es einen harten lockt dann über wochen
und da war sie bei 149 1 oder was also
ist so eine form von relation aber sagen
wir das ist die eine variante die andere
ist dass wir so was machen wir in europa
so sagt dass wir versuchen damit zurecht
zu kommen hier unter diesen die ich
deswegen hab ich sie liegen den
traunsteiner planen mit fünf schritten
die sind alle durchdacht das ist ein
junger csu-politiker 36 der sagt das
geht so irgendwie nicht weiter wir
müssen das anders mal also entweder
versuchen das oder wir machen eine no go
it strategie
und sage mir keiner das gehe nicht die
bundeskanzler der bundesrepublik
deutschland ist nach den aussagen des
führenden deutschen staatsrechtlers
christoph möllers vom möller von der who
in der lage das anzuordnen dann muss sie
uns offene gehen und muss sagen ich bin
der meinung ich habe bis jetzt immer
recht gehabt ich bin der meinung dass
das so nicht weitergeht jetzt machen wir
das wenn ihr was dagegen habt dann geht
in die parlamente oder gehen hier werden
im deutschen bundestag oder verklagt
mich aber das können wir mal das sage
nicht ich sondern das gibt
offensichtlich die verfassung her
das ist eine form von politischer führen
habe ich mal sagen das ist so ein
bisschen beiden mäßig das machen wir
jetzt ich habe die angeordnet die ganzen
geschichten
das wird nicht passieren also wenn wir
sagen no go wild kommt nicht dann müssen
die logisch was anderes und ich sage
nochmal so kann es einfach nicht
weitergehen wir können nicht immer
weiter immer weiter immer weiter an
genug kopitz strategie die hätte man ja
in den letzten jahren ist eigentlich
anwenden müssen das hat man nicht
angewendet wie ist denn das mit mit dem
lockdown überhaupt der jetzt ja so
wellenbewegungen hat mal ist er etwas
stärker mal etwas weniger stark war das
so gerade wichtig immer das gemacht hat
oder was zu viel was zu wenig gibt es da
verpasste gelegenheiten sind wir lernen
wir auch nicht aus unserer eigenen
corona vergangenheit
ich glaube verpasste gelegenheiten gab
es mindestens zwei fallen mir ein im
letzten herbst als frau merkel schon
gesagt hat
also da gab es diese bund länder
konferenz und es war offensichtlich dass
frau merkel gesagt hat wir müssen jetzt
lockdown machen weil auch damals schon
epidemiologen gezeigt haben wenn wir
jetzt noch weiter warten
dann steigt dann steigt die zahl der
infizierten die dem land haben und je
höher die ist umso härter wird es
nachher um die wieder runter zu kriegen
weil umso schwieriger ist es für die
gesundheitsämter wieder fuß zu fassen
und das ist eine ganz wichtige größe die
man nicht vergessen darf
damals wollten die ministerpräsidenten
nicht einige jedenfalls und deswegen
wurde es verschoben zwei wochen später
haben sich alle wieder getroffen und es
war klar es geht kein weg dran vorbei
irgendwann ist die situation man sagt
jetzt müssen wir an ihm reden ziehen
sonst streiten die intensivmediziner
weil die müssen es ausbaden die leute
die im krankenhaus arbeiten
die haben jetzt schon wieder angst was
ostern los ist und die andere chance war
vor zwei wochen beim papst als gelockert
wurde als entschieden wurde vor zwei
wochen ja auch da gab es glasklare
prophezeiung berechnung keine
prophezeiung
mathematische modellierung von wirklich
guten leuten die international anerkannt
sind wie vorher schon recht gehabt haben
mit ihren prognosen
da konnte man absehen was passiert wenn
wir jetzt nicht warten und mal habt
nicht gewartet weil angeblich der druck
aus dem volk so groß war ich weiß nicht
ob man nicht hätte sagen können leute
noch zwei wochen und wir haben die
zahlen auch nicht nur wird aber
vielleicht bei 10 oder bei 25 oder sowas
das ist dann beherrscht war dann ist es
nicht mehr so unkontrollierbar
wir sind jetzt wieder in den
unkontrollierbaren zuschauer so die
nerven verloren
ja zu früh gesagt paar politiker haben
dann gesagt weil jetzt wahlkampf ist
mensch das geht nicht das volk will
nicht mehr
wenn man dann noch zwei wochen
durchgehalten hätte eine andere basis
euer ehren
das problem ist man kann politik nicht
gegen das volk machen nicht auf dauer
deshalb legt das heißt es ist zb also
air china sollte das alles ist erklärt
worden oder ich jedenfalls meine ich das
verstanden zu haben sie haben auch
gesagt erklärt worden ja aber wir haben
parlament und ich finde das hätte schon
viel häufiger viel öfter im parlament
verhandelt werden müssen damit auch die
bevölkerung das gefühl hat dass sie
gehört wird wofür heißt dass
volksvertretung
das ist auch ein ganz wesentlicher
aspekt und da hätte man das verhandeln
können wie ich finde dann gehst du mal
um mal und tag um tag in das im
deutschen bundestag und waren es dieses
thema aus neuler gibt es laut experten
gibt es widerstreitende interessen da
geht es hin und her
wir müssen auch ein bisschen aufpassen
dass wir unsere demokratie nicht
schreddern also volks pädagogik zu sagen
das machen wir jetzt hier so und das hat
jetzt so zu sein dass führt irgendwann
an die grenze deswegen die beteiligung
des parlaments
da stehe ich allein herbert fandel
autor der süddeutschen zeitung andere
die fdp das ist ja nicht alles falsch
wenn die auf bürgerrechte verfassung
aufgrund auf grundsätze hinweisen wir
müssen uns auch darum bemühen das was
uns auszeichnet zu erhalten dabei heißt
wie würde ein neubau starken red
demokratie vorher würde ich aber gerne
herrn schieritz noch das wort gärten
ich bin nicht so überzeugt weil ich
nicht weiß wie viele leute
bundestagsdebatten verfolgen oder das
anschauen sollten mehr sein aber ich
weiß nicht ob das nicht ein bisschen so
ein pappkamerad ist zu sagen dass
parlament und dann ist alles erledigt am
16 in china sieht eine demokratie ist
ein pub kamera hat der bundestag ein
paar männer an demokratischen
entscheidungen sind die
ministerpräsidenten gewählt und die
entscheidung der punkt ist doch wir uns
einfach nicht wahr das ist doch der
punkt das ist ja auch nicht so dass da
irgendwie rollo gesagt und soll ich
kenne nicht möchte euch jetzt mit meinen
zahlen sondern die entwicklungen sind so
wie sie sind und ich mich zwar auch
immer dran aber trotzdem muss man sagen
dass die leute das berechnet haben schon
relativ gut gerechnet haben und dass die
modelle offensichtlich einfach nicht so
schlecht
wir hatten drei anläufe wir haben
dreimal nicht glauben wollen und es
kamen aber trotzdem mal wieder so und
jetzt würde ich sagen sind wir in einer
phase wo das das ist vorbei also die die
exit strategie die es jetzt noch gibt es
das impfen
man muss alle kraft darauf ersetzen zu
impfen der brauchen glaube jetzt nicht
mit neuen anderen strategien noch um
experimentieren beide implementiert sein
wird sagen sie wir schon alle geimpft
also das ist das was wir jetzt noch
machen können und dann damit sich das
auch nicht ewig hinziehen sondern sind
bgm
und dann kommen wir da raus aber wir
haben natürlich chancen verpasst aber
dachten wir können das virus irgendwie
austricksen
das ist herrlich genommen also um das
einmal klarzustellen das gremium dass
sie angesprochen haben das gibt es gar
nicht in der verfassung gibt es kein
gremium das die minister präsident und
die bundeskanzlerin zusammen führt das
in der verfassung nicht vorgesehen was
in der verfassung vorgesehen ist ist
dass die politik sich durch
meinungsbildung im parlament äusserst
wenn das parlament ich wollte könnte ich
auch eine neue regierung sich wählen so
ist das nämlich es ist nicht wir sind
keine exekutiv demokratie wo von oben
runter regiert wird sagen wir mal
böses theorem aber gute tyrannen
regieren nein sondern ist die
volksvertretung welt sich notfalls eine
neue regierung deswegen ich bin nicht
naiv natürlich wird das nicht ständig im
fernsehen angesehen werden millionen
werden dann plötzlich fertig was ich ihn
wünschen will das angucken aber die
rückkopplung die teilt sich sehr wohl
mit
die teilt sich jedem mit weil das dann
auch immer wieder und über alle kanäle
auf welchem kanal auch immer berichtet
werden wird oder berichtet worden wäre
jetzt teile ich ihre meinung jetzt muss
geimpft werden
auf corona teufel komm raus und dann
wird es besser diskutiert ist wird doch
in aller breite trendforschern sozusagen
diskutieren die verschiedenen optionen
und alle melden sich zu wort also ich
sehe einfach nicht wie das parlament
diskutiert ja auch das grab regierung
ist der aktuelle stunden usw
ich weiß nicht ob das irgendetwas man
sozusagen
wir brauchen mehr debatte oder irgendwie
erinnert ist in der regel nichts anderes
mehr sagen ja ich würde gerne wenn da
die maschen vorerst ausgetauscht sind
gerne herr neubauer noch mal fragen weil
wir jetzt gerade auf feld hinter ihnen
ist zu lesen stadt augustusburg eine
stadt mit weitsicht
vielleicht sind sie ja auch eine insel
der seligen im südlichen sachsen weil es
gibt ja in ihrer gegend viele landkreise
mit sehr hohen institutionen gibt es
denn ähnliche initiativen ihrer kollegen
bürgermeister landräte die sich da auch
ein vorbild nehmen an dem was
augustusburg macht um diese auch diese
ganzen spannung diese ganzen konflikte
die ja entstehen zwischen politik und
bevölkerung gerade in diesem teil der
bundesrepublik etwas rauszunehmen ja nun
ein bisschen also keine heiligsprechung
von meiner person oder dem was wir hier
machen es gibt eine menge leute die
damit mit tun und es gibt auch
inzwischen eine menge städte die sich
dem hier anschließen
also wir machen das gerade oder das wird
gerade so ein bisschen im selbstlauf
möglicherweise eine sächsische lösung
was mich sehr freut wir haben das auch
von anfang an so gemacht dass alle
erkenntnisse die wir haben alle konzepte
die wir haben wir open source stehen ab
sonntag gibt es eine webseite wo man
sich
alles runterladen kann was man dazu
braucht inklusive dem antrag für ein
solches projekt bei der landesregierung
das haben wir alles ganz bewusst so
gemacht wir haben aber trotzdem muss man
zurückspulen weil wenn ich dann so höre
so pappkamerad und selbst wenn wir mehr
machen gucken die leute ja nicht ich
glaube wir überspringen einiges in der
diskussion warum ist es denn so dass
menschen sich nicht mehr für politik
interessieren das ist doch die
eigentliche frage und ich kann diese
dieses märchen von politikverdrossenheit
wirklich nicht mehr hören weil die
menschen sind politisch das problem ist
dass das system in dem wir hier
operieren wahrscheinlich eine flughöhe
erreicht hat die für manchen nicht mehr
zu sehen ist durch die wolkendecke das
muss man ganz klar sagen wir sind auf
dem weg wirklich die ebene wo menschen
das mit dem leben kontakt haben wo sie
sehen vor ihrer nase was passiert und wo
man ihnen beibringen könnte was es
bedeutet sich einzubringen
hier machen wir mangelverwaltung während
wir anderswo die entscheidung treffen
und das kann nicht mehr so sein und das
haben wir lange lange zeit gemacht und
das war's jetzt sichtbar wird dass
dieses desinteresse da ist dass es in
wut umschlägt quasi sofort hat ganz alte
wurzeln das darf man bei der debatte
wirklich vergessen war immer so dieser
landstrich in dem ich erlebe immer so
irgendwie das neue dunkel deutschland
wird und dagegen wehre ich mich ein
bisschen weil das sehr pauschal ist und
hoch lebe die differenzierung in der
debatte also dann müssen wir uns dann
schon mal positiv dass wir wieder beim
thema dass die politik durch die
pandemie jetzt seit etwas mehr als einem
jahr klar überfordert ist
ich finde eigentlich bisher also
zumindest im letzten jahr hat sich
unsere politik ganz gut geschlagen es
gab recht leute die hoffnungslos
überfordert waren die hießen am anfang
boris johnson und donald trump und
bolzen abo oder wie auch immer die haben
auch richtig viele menschen auf dem
gewissen da sind tausende zehntausende
gestorben weil dieser sich ernst
genommen haben das war hier anders wir
haben bis jetzt immer noch recht relativ
wenig todesfälle
wir haben bisher immer noch keinen
zusammenbruch unseres gesundheitssystems
das war in spanien in italien das war
den niederlanden wie viele patienten
haben die schon nach hinten
nordrhein-westfalen geschickt weil sie
überlastet waren das waren vielen vielen
ländern schlechter in vielen ländern in
einigen ländern war es auch besser in
asien zum beispiel in neuseeland in
israel die sind ja klein sie sind
kompakter die sind vielleicht auch in
anderen situationen es hätte ich jetzt
besser laufen können wir jetzt so viel
versprochen wurde ja aber es ist ja
nicht so dass irgendein politiker gesagt
hat ich bin gegen schimpfen oder
natürlich wollen wir auch alle dass viel
geld wird
ich möchte noch einen punkt an führen
weil ganz am anfang gesagt wurde dass es
wichtig ist dass man jetzt schnell ist
und nicht immer so dass die deutschen
aber auch so ist lieben so exakt so zu
sein als das anfing das bekannt wurde
dass in dem ein oder anderen städtchen
impfdosen übrig waren und dann leute
geimpft wurden die nicht dran waren in
der reihenfolge weil die gerade am
rathaus vorbei kam oder weil an einer
gesagt hätte wir haben jetzt zehn dosen
übrig jetzt schon mal die feuerwehr ran
da ich die wegschmeißen kriegen die die
da war auch der ein oder andere dabei er
hat es vielleicht geplant und das war
eine schweinerei
aber manchmal war es auch einfach gut
das ist jetzt nicht die richtige
priorität gruppe aber ich das zeug weg
schmeiße hat der arzt gesagt dann
verängstigt dass und da sind dann viele
deutsche und auch leider in den medien
gerade die zeitung mit den großen
buchstaben so schnell dabei mit einer
neiddebatte dass sich doch jeder arzt
fragen muss mache ich das noch so schön
wenn wir deutsche in der pandemie auch
lernen damit etwas anders umzugehen und
die dinge etwas anders zu betreiben das
ist schon auch mal hilfreich ja also
zusehen dass die ubs würde die
bundeskanzlerin sagte mann oder sagte
mal dass seit über komplexes fand ich
wundervoll
ja ich sage ich spreche nicht für unter
komplexität aber eine gewisse form von
lebensnähe von praktischem handeln also
von von praxisorientierung und von
praktischer intelligenz das ist schon
auch willkommen jetzt und das verbunden
mit ausreichend ich bestehe darauf mit
ausreichend diskussion da wo es darauf
ankommt und zwar in den parlamenten
damit dass rückgekoppelt ist um die
demokratie wirksam zu halten
das ist schon auch notwendig und das
kostet keine zeit der wähler auftrag
lautet ja gutes regieren damit meine ich
jetzt allerdings die arbeit der
parlamente mit eingeschlossen bei diesen
begriff gutes regieren die ist das wenn
man dann hört es gebe ein partielles
politik und stadt
herzversagen man will ja nicht sagen
staatsversagen das ist ja das fertigen
von extremisten aber sein sagen us
politik und staatsversagen ist das
ungerechtfertigt und warum wird mit
diesen begriffen hantiert
das müssen sie mal die fragen die das
tun das ist natürlich profan und das ist
natürlich vordergründig ist doch klar
dass eine chance für radikale das ist
eine chance für extremisten zu sagen
seht her die schaffen das nicht so
politik ist das ist wohl auch eben auf
der anderen seite war ist natürlich
komplexer das ist also die form von
politik wie wir sie hier in deutschland
betreibung gottseidank danke danke dafür
betreiben ist natürlich auch komplexe
das heißt du musst die dinge erläutern
du musst um gefolgschaft werben
du kannst es nicht einfach durchsetzen
du musst eben beschlüsse herbeiführen so
und deswegen wird von staatsversagen
gesprochen ich kann auch nicht finden
das staatsversagen gebt unser
gesundheitssystem ist zwar mit 100
milliarden pro jahr 110 milliarden pro
jahr gepolstert dennoch ist es großartig
dass es hält also da kann man sagen im
gegenteil die der staat hat in noch
nicht mehr in kenntnis schon war panini
aber sagen wir so hat über die jahre hin
ja offensichtlich gute arbeit geleistet
dass wir das alles schaffen können
anders als andere länder unser
gesundheitssystem ist haltesignalen
besser als das in italien das ja ich
würde auch nicht von kritik geratenen
staatsversagen sprechen aber natürlich
gemacht und die sind passiert und das
muss man auch kritisiert jetzt auch die
aufgabe von uns als journalistin oder
als experten dass das zu kritisieren
ich glaube das problem ist was in
deutschland und das hat schon mit der
politischen grundkonstellation zu tun
ist das was die ansatz leadership nennen
dass er politische führungen die
kanzlerin ist ihren weg seien im im
september da gibt es dann so ein loch in
der mitte des landes sozusagen und
deswegen fällt es halt auch so schwer
kontroverse maßnahmen durchzusetzen also
was dennoch dauern an geht aber auch im
beim impfen zusagen kommen egal auch
wenn sich die man viel sparen wir
kämpfen jetzt einfach und wenn ihr ein
wenig ausgeholt mir das auch nicht so
schlimm sollte das braucht natürlich
politische kraft das durchzustehen und
da habe ich von den
dass die wenig gefehlt in dieser zweiten
welle der krise ich habe jetzt das
schlusswort der sendung zu vergeben denn
wir haben doch ziemlich genau eine
minute und 20 sekunden
dass wir dieses jahr ein wahljahr haben
erschwert dass die lösung der probleme
über die wir gesprochen haben gibt es ja
vielleicht sogar einen selbstblockade
absolut wir haben jetzt schon geht es
los dass ich das gefühl habe dass
politiker anderer an karren fahren für
irgendwas und probleme hochbau shen weis
jetzt politisch ans eingemachte geht
weiß um die wählerstimmen geben das
können wir wirklich nicht brauchen
das können wir wirklich nicht brauchen
es geht jetzt hier nicht um die
einzelnen parteien es geht jetzt hier
wirklich darum kluge entscheidungen zu
treffen damit wir in den sommer kommen
weil dann wird es besser im sommer wird
mit wird weiter über noch für einen
ergänzungs satz schönes wort
gemeinwohlorientierung und das muss
sogar im wahlkampf geld gut das wir
haben
foto lorenz ja da haben wir jetzt eben
bis zum 6 september noch eine menge
phoenix runde wo wir genau das
nachprüfen können ich bedanke mich bei
christina satori bei stephan andreas
casdorff bei dirk neubauer und bei mark
schieritz liebe zuschauer wir bleiben am
ball sowie das virus auch bei uns bleibt
am kommenden sonntag 12 uhr der
internationale frühschoppen wird sich
natürlich auch mit dem thema pandemie
beschäftigen und phoenix am montag den
ganzen lieben langen tag denn die
ministerpräsidenten treffen auf die
bundeskanzlerin die
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten auf die
bundeskanzlerin
es geht um mögliche verschärfung oder
verlängerung des locker und 22 15 uhr am
montag unter den linden mit michaela
kolster und gast ist dort unter anderem
karl lauterbach bleiben sie bei uns